en los últimos días el Rey Carlos III ha
visitado las cuatro regiones del Reino
Unido para de una u otra manera
presentarse como el nuevo monarca Carlos
fue el primer Rey británico en visitar
esta región en 80 años de historia y
esto nos muestra el tipo de relación que
trata de tener el nuevo monarca con esta
región que se ve un poco apartada del
resto de Gran Bretaña Me parece bien
interesante de los símbolos que vimos
hoy en el funeral de estado de la Reina
Isabel segunda repito histórico porque
porque la ministra principal de Irlanda
del norte de la republicana del chimpan
Michelle o'neal asistido recordemos que
los republicanos no reconocen la corona
y por el contrario
quisieran la reunificación de la isla de
la isla de Irlanda de la República con
la parte que está dentro del Reino Unido
y que quiere parte del Reino Unido pero
Michelle o'neal está aquí en el funeral
de estado de Isabel segunda ha dicho en
un mensaje en Twitter que ha reconocido
la figura de Isabel segunda y esto nos
muestra por supuesto la influencia y la
importancia de Isabel como símbolo
tratando de unir a todas las regiones
británicas no tenemos certeza qué va a
pasar en el futuro hablabas de Escocia
Escocia un lugar importantísimo y
fundamental para la familia real
británica y muy en el corazón de Isabel
segunda porque era uno de sus lugares
favoritos del país quisiera
independizarse del Reino Unido y de
hecho la ministra principal escocesa
Nicolás ha planteado hace un par de
meses la fecha posible de un segundo
referendo de Independencia por supuesto
esto necesita el visto bueno de Londres
por ahora no lo tiene pero hablamos de
la importancia y lo que trata de hacer
el Rey Carlos II que es tratar de
mantener al Reino Unido unificado no
sabemos en el futuro que va a pasar pero
la asistencia de Michel onil hoy aquí al
funeral de estado de Isabel II es bien
bien significativo porque representa el
partido que no reconoce la democracia de
hecho el chimpan Tiene asientos en el
Palacio de Westminster en el parlamento
británico pero como tiene los diputados
que jurar lealtad a la reina Simplemente
no toma sus asientos y Es bien
interesante como entonces empieza a
transformarse y como el Rey Carlos
tercero y también Isabel segunda en su
funeral ha tratado de mantener las
cuatro regiones británicas juntas